today i am a very happy and excited man
because apple
out of the blue just updated their intel
based imax
and there were a couple of things that
we were really really hoping for
and we already ordered two of these 5k
imacs
so if you want to see us test them go
ahead and subscribe
right now we just ordered a twenty three
hundred dollar eight core
and a thirty three hundred dollar ten
core model both of them with only eight
gigs of ram
because we're going to upgrade it
ourselves to 64 gigs of ram
for only around 230 dollars instead of a
thousand dollars from the apple website
and we'll leave links to that ram down
below so you can buy it yourself
and yes you can still upgrade it
yourself
because if you look at this image from
the new imac listing page
it clearly shows of the ram door behind
the stand
what makes me excited is that my
predictions from my last imac rumor
video
were almost completely correct except
for one feature
that is disappointingly missing on the
5k imac
so what i'm going to do in this video is
go through all of the changes
and compare them to the previous models
so you know exactly what changed and how
much it actually matters
and if you're as excited as i am
definitely go down below and check out
our apple product pattern t-shirt
in our merch shelf just below this video
and by the way
before we get started the imac pro got a
tiny update
for the same base price you now get the
10 core processor
instead of the previous 8 core now
getting into all of the changes
every single imac including the 21.5
inch model
now comes with an ssd at the base price
so no more hard drives
and that's basically the only change for
the 21.5 inch imac
which is really weird because apple
usually updates both of them at the same
time
this shows that apple is planning to
replace the smaller imac model
with their apple silicon 24-inch imac
either later this year in october
or they might wait until early 2021. now
let's get into the new
inch 5k imac which starts at the same
base price of 17.99
except that we now get intel's latest
10gen chips on every configuration
and now you can get up to a 3.6
gigahertz
10 core i9 processor which is going to
be insane
previously the best choice was an 8 core
i9
and based on apple's performance charts
this new cpu is much more powerful
than the old acor as far as the design
it hasn't changed which is a bit
disappointing
but honestly the internal changes are
huge this year
and as far as the display it's basically
staying unchanged
except that you now have an option to
pay for the nano texture glass
which apple offered on their 6k pro
display xdr
which basically turns it into a high
quality matte display
without using a film that ruins the
colors and the contrast
you can now configure the ram up to 128
gigs
from apple for a massive 2600
but we do not recommend doing so because
you can buy four sticks of that ram that
we link to down below
and you'll get 128 gigs for only around
four hundred and sixty-five dollars
instead of two thousand
six hundred dollars you can now also
configure up to a massive
eight terabyte ssd which is a huge
difference
coming from the previous maximum of 2
terabytes
now there are three major features that
matter the most to
us as video editors and one of them is
the new graphics
the previous base 5k imac came with the
radeon pro 570x gpu
and the new one comes with the radeon
pro 5300
which is based on amd's new navi
graphics architecture which has a number
of advantages
the previous best gpu was the vega 48
and you can now get up to a 5700 xt
which is our favorite graphics card to
use in an egpu setup
because it's just so dang fast but this
isn't like
any other 5700 xt this one is the only
one
that comes with 16 gigs of vram which
you can't get on a pc
this is going to be a really big deal
for anybody doing graphics rendering
work
and finally the new imac now gets a
1080p
facetime camera which was only ever
available on the imac
pro so here's a quick comparison video
showing the difference between the 720p
webcam and the imac pro's 1080p webcam
so you can know what to expect apple
also added a new studio
quality 3 microphone array with new
features
compared to a basic mic on the previous
imac
so if you want to see us test that
definitely subscribe down below so you
don't miss out
and the second major feature that
matters the most to us
is the fact that the 5k imac now finally
gets apple's t2 chip
which enables hey siri and a bunch of
other features
this matters a lot to us because the
macbook pro
used to outperform a much more powerful
5k imac
in terms of hevc video export speed
simply because the imac didn't have a t2
chip
which takes care of hevc encoding and
decoding
so this change alone is huge for video
editors
another great feature is the fact that
you can hook up not one
but two 6k displays thanks to the new
knobby graphics
which support the latest version of
display stream compression
the previous 5k imac could only support
one 5k display
or two 4k displays this is going to be
big
for a lot of high-end editing studios
now as far as the ports
they're basically staying the same
except for two of them
the first being the sd card slot which
now supports
uh s2 speeds the previous imac limited
transfer speeds to around 100 megabytes
per second
compared to the new sd card slot which
supports speeds up to around 280
megabytes per second
so editors can now rejoice but the third
major feature that matters the most to
us
is the fact that you can now finally
have an option to get
a 10 gigabit ethernet port we here at
maxtec use a shared raid server that
requires either 10 gig
ethernet or thunderbolt 3 to get the
fastest transfer speeds for editing
and since we already used up the two
thunderbolt 3 ports
my mac has to connect using 10 gig
ethernet
that's basically the only reason why i'm
currently using an
imac pro instead of a 5k imac
and now that the new 5k imac has a 10
gig ethernet option
we're literally gonna sell my imac pro
and our editor angelica's 5k imac
and keep the new 5k imax that we just
ordered and that's because i'm 100
confident that the new 3300 5k imac
is going to destroy the 5 000 imac pro
in terms of performance
and we'll actually be doing a comparison
video before we sell it
and now finally i want to mention the
one feature
that i incorrectly predicted and that's
wi-fi six
the new imac still has wi-fi five now to
us
that's not a very big deal at all
because we don't have internet fast
enough
to really take advantage of wi-fi 6. but
it's definitely nice that the new 5k
imac now gets bluetooth 5
instead of bluetooth 4.2 on the previous
models
and there you guys have it that's
basically all of the new features and
changes
and i'm extremely excited because apple
gave us everything that we asked for
and we know these new imacs are gonna
absolutely
destroy performance wise and we're
definitely going to compare it to
our 15 000 mac pro now i want to let you
guys know that as of right now
i'm already working on the 2020 5k imac
buyers guide
so if you're not sure which model you
should buy or which
upgrades you should pay for click that
circle above right now so you don't miss
out on that video
and definitely go down below and check
out our new apple product merch
thanks for watching and i'll see you
very soon in the buyer's guide video
you